Christie is going to start off this hour
in Detroit Michigan hi Christie how are
you I'm good how are you Dave better
than I deserve what's up I have a
question for you I found out in August
that my husband of seven years has a
gambling problem and he had been hiding
money taking money out of our retirement
accounts our 401 K Roth IRA every
paycheck to fund this habit and I didn't
know about it
Oh Margaret counseling yeah so we're in
counseling to deal with you know the
trust issue of it and he's in Gamblers
Anonymous and doing everything he should
be doing but the question is how can we
best utilize the cash envelope system if
I don't really want him to be carrying
cash okay um well here's the thing okay
you've got a freshly uh turned addict
here's one month of track record okay
and one hunt we work with addicts a lot
sadly not because we work with
addictions but because 100 percent of
addicts have financial problems
eventually and so we end up dealing with
this and have for 20 years so here's a
couple of things we know about addicts
one is they can turn it around and there
can be a wonderful story at the end of
this to is they lie a lot as you have
discovered and
so for you to rebuild trust in your
counseling process which I commend you
for engaging in that that's you've done
the exact things you should have done
for you to rebuild trust takes T IME
time and so again you're asking the
exact perfect question of how do I
handle money in this situation he has
lost his right to handle money in any
way until a level of trust is rebuilt
now after a level of trust is rebuilt he
can handle some more money and if that
goes well
in more money and then someday you know
we will consider him healed and dry and
uh you know that the two of you can just
handle money together like a quote
normal couple
somewhere out there but there needs to
be a length of time a good length of
time before that occurs that he's clean
and that he continues on his Gamblers
Anonymous meetings and that you know
that you're seeing all the right stuff
happening you follow me I do so seven
years from today you wouldn't treat him
like you treated me today seven months
from today you might not even treat him
like you treat him today but today he's
at Ground Zero he gets no money and his
name should be off of all the accounts
that's what I did I we took his name off
of our joint checking and we actually
opened him a small checking account of
his own where he gets about $25 a week
much one for that's okay so that money
can be tracked through a debit card
that's fine yeah that's great
and if you want to give him a little
cash that's fine $25 a week is not going
to cause him to relapse okay he's been
spending thousands yeah okay $25 is not
even a you know it's not if I got a
lottery ticket purchase you know so um
it's just you know plus he'd be hungry
then he won't be able to buy food and
then the you know the red flags will go
up right because that's what this is for
is he you know his lunches or whatever
right right that what it's for
yeah I think you just treat him like um
you know you're at Ground Zero with
trust here and so there's no there's no
dignity for an addict at this level they
don't have any dignity it's they're
stripped of it because they're turning
their life around thank goodness it's
wonderful and dignity returns with trust
and Trust returns with trust worthiness
the worthiness to be trusted and that
comes with time and so yeah you know for
the next few months $25 on a debit card
a separate account make sure all your
passwords are changed on all your
accounts and all the all the retirement
and everything oh okay he needs no
access to anything period and that's not
to punish him it's to protect you and
him from a crash rate from him crashing
again and because you know he's really
on his last straw here with you probably
and he's definitely on his last straw
financially because he's about stripped
the family dry yeah I mean there was a
lot of money that got lost luckily we're
not in terrible shape because we had
been saving a lot but we could be better
oh yeah well I mean you caught it early
then because a lot of times you're out
you're down there at the edge of
bankruptcy by the time you find it so
again none of this is to punish him you
didn't hear punitive in my voice I hope
it's to protect him and to protect you
and it's not a permanent we're going to
treat him like he's four years old
permanently but for today I'm altering
muggies for okay and that's what I was
worried about just you know how long
should I continue to monitor every
single dime that is getting spent
because I don't want him to feel like
I'm belittling him in any way but I oh
you're not belittling him you're
belittling what he's done okay
it's you know we love the sinner hate
the sin and so what he's been doing is
caused him to break trust at a very very
deep level and so Trust has to be
rebuilt and that takes some time so I
think you and your counselor and him can
monitor that and he gets you know more
he gets more and more dignity more and
more I almost call it like we age him
we're starting him at four and then
we'll take him to 14 and then we'll take
him to 24 and then we'll take him to his
current age you know in terms of how
they a level of responsibility and
access to funds that he has but that all
comes with some time and you know before
he gets back to full access it's at
least a year Ellie's year okay full
access unlimited unbridled access at
least a year yeah I mean because this is
a strong addiction it's got a strong
pull this guy was in the process of
destroying his life and yours yeah and
I'm just lucky that I have been
dissemble upon it yeah it was all by
accident well I think God saved you so
you know and he'll so it's great news
and can a gambling addict turn it around
yes we see a lot of them turn it around
but they have to do the things that you
and I are talking about and that you've
already done before you got to me and
that was you know marriage counseling
for the two of you
you and he's plugged in with a counselor
and a coach and he's in GA and
absolutely by the way in case you didn't
know
gambling addiction is the fastest
growing addiction in North America today
on a curve like you wouldn't believe
actually its second fastest is porn yeah
we learned that by watching some of your
YouTube videos so okay yeah pointed porn
is number one and gambling is number two
and we are seeing those two things in
our offices with family's finances
ruined literally every day every day we
see and so it's very very real and both
of those that the speed of the growth of
that has had a lot to do with internet
access to both and you got access to
stuff now that you never had access to
do too in other generations and and it
just causes people to destroy their
lives is really really really sad so
hope that's helpful to you Christie will
be happy to walk with you and him I'm
proud of him he's doing the right stuff
as you guys turn this around so hey hold
on I'm of Kelly make sure you're in
Financial Peace University we want that
to be part of your financial healing and
part of his financial healing this is
the Dave Ramsey show
hey guys Rachael Cruz here hope you
enjoyed that video from the Dave Ramsey
show if you want to watch another great
video check out my video three things
you should consider renting right over
here or click the link in the
description below